en 2014 la médiathèque de roanne
accueille dans ses collections un
recueil de cartes du dix septième siècle
signé guy roux du pain ce que vous allez
voir retrace le récit d'une course
contre la montre depuis l'annnonce de la
vente aux enchères jusqu'à l'acquisition
d'une oeuvre extraordinaire
il me restait un quart d'heure la
journée a été quand même journée
d'attenté fébrile
voilà on n'était pas sûr de l'avoir leur
mission impossible
comment cette petite ville à l'est tel
pouvoir rivaliser et remporté l'enchère
la pac
non pas lapin avec l'acquisition
patrimoniale d'intérêt national donc il
a fallu construire un ce dos plan de
financement ce sont des enveloppes qui
l'une et l'autre je crois nullement ont
cinquante mille et 60000 euros
donc c'est vrai que c'est pas des
enveloppes non plus sur dimensionné j'ai
eu des gs qui m'a appelé un jour il m'a
dit bon combien on y met alors moi
j'étais complètement dans le flou
artistique le plus total et je me
souviens lui avoir annoncé mais de
manière un peu dubitatif comme ça bah
50000 et il m'a dit bon ok alors
allons-y pour 58 donc 50 milles ça veut
dire que c'est le prix marteau se dire
l'enchère maximum que nous allions y
mettre et si c'était 50000 012 montant
d'adjudications c'était foutu donc il a
fallu déclencher une procédure d'urgence
et comme on avait laissé traîner un peu
au début la date de vente aux enchères
avancé à grands pas et on fait tout ce
qui fait environ une semaine et demie
pour refaire un petit peu l'historique
du document on se situe à la fin du
règne de louis xiv fait on a voulu
accentuer ou renforcer le commerce par
voie fluviale
sauf que la loire au niveau de roanne
était de praticable le pouvoir royal a
souhaité canalise
et a ordonné la construction de trois
digues guy roux du parc pendant les
travaux a dessiné et réalisé des
planches aquarellés à la main pour
rendre compte
on suppose qu'on suppose au pouvoir
royal de ces travaux-là donc ses
planches sont vraiment très très belle
facture et elles ont été reliés aux
armes 2014
alors j'ai énormément de collègues qui
se souviennent de ce moment où nous
avons le livre est revenu ou nous
l'avons fêté ensemble et en effet on a
été tous en admiration devant aussi la
beauté des couleurs des pigments le
caractère enfin l'état extrêmement bien
conservés du document cette première
étape réussi leur mission n'est pourtant
pas achevé les agents spéciaux de la mrh
doit désormais se confronter au public -
qui fait des études d'histoire c'est
vrai que ya cette importance du document
et puis le fait qu'on puisse avoir voilà
ce bien en nos murs et pouvoir le
proposer aux lecteurs
on a eu le temps de le feuilleter et
puis après pour l'exposition qui a suivi
il ya eu des très grandes productions /
bages fait qui faisait la taille de la
hauteur des murs quand on fait ce genre
d'ouvragé à la médiathèque de roanne
l'intérêt pour nous c'était toute la
population depuis son puissent en
profiter on prendre connaissance le voir
créer des variations autour de ce
document via le numérique de manière
ludique de manière
un petit peu novatrice on avait une des
bâches qui représentait des extraits du
gheer ou du bas entre autres la scène où
on voit les différents métiers sur la
digue en train de se construire
et puis on a le château de la roche et
les gens nous disaient ah bah nous on
allait dans les ruines du château jouer
quand on était enfant fin on a eu des
balles à des anecdotes de deux personnes
locales c'est un document qui est tout
aussi esthétiquement que dans le fond
très important pour la connaissance
qu'on peut avoir de ceux de notre
territoire
et puis en plus comme je vous le disais
qui a une répercussion directe sur ce
que vivent aujourd'hui les rouennais à
travers ces aménagements de bord de
loire ça redonne du sens à notre action
là on était vraiment au coeur de ce qui
est important et en plus de ce qui nous
engage par rapport à l'héritage qu'on a
reçu de nos insectes 20 de nos
prédécesseurs et qu'on va pouvoir
transmettre ils veulent pouvoir
transmettre enrichi de quelque chose de
remarquable la bonne morale de cette
histoire c'est qu'ils vouent toujours
tenter l'impossible est vraiment pas
français
[Musique]